zdf heute live herzlich willkommen seit
monaten geistert das thema durchs land
und man kann sagen ab morgen wird es
ernst es geht um die impfpflicht und
morgen diskutiert der bundestag in einer
so genannten orientierungs debatte über
das für und wider und dabei werden dann
auch verschiedene modelle vorgeschlagen
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
voraussichtlich zwischen februar und
märz soll dann über das gesetz
entschieden werden und zwar in form von
gruppen anträgen also ohne
fraktionszwang wir aber diskutieren
schon heute abend über dieses thema und
zwar mit unseren gästen da hätten wir
zum einen die
spd-bundestagsabgeordnete und juso
chefin jessica rosenthal sie ist für
eine impfpflicht für alle ab 18 einen
schönen guten abend und
ich freue mich sehr wir uns auch anderer
ansicht ist der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete maximilian
mottos was die impfpflicht angeht er ist
strikt dagegen auch ihnen herzlich
willkommen schönen guten abend vielen
dank so und bei uns im studio last but
not least ist wieder sehr attacke da
freuen wir uns außerdem dass sie bei uns
ist die leiterin der zdf redaktion recht
und justiz sie wird uns helfen noch mal
die verschiedenen positionen rechtlich
zu beleuchten auch die er natürlich
einen schönen guten abend sarah ja dann
fangen wir mal an mit einem vielleicht
ersten kurzen schlagabtausch frau
rosenthal in wenigen worten wenn sie es
mal knapp machen müssen warum sind sie
für eine impfpflicht
weil ich fest der überzeugung bin dass
wir jetzt bevölkerung in dem es werden
müssen und das bedeutet dass eben alle
einen grundschutz haben und wir dann
auch wieder dazu kommen können zu öffnen
freiheiten zurückzugeben und es nicht
sein kann dass die die ungeimpft sind
die solidarität von denen so weiter
einfordern wie das bisher ist da muss
einfach was passieren herr mordhorst
warum sind sie dagegen
wir haben zur zeit eine völlig
unzureichende datenlage was die
wirkliche wirkung in bezug auf das von
jessica angesprochene thema endemische
lage angeht insbesondere mit bezug auf
die omikron variante die jetzt voll im
rausch ist und wir wissen auch bei
vielen anderen dingen nicht
wie könnte es wirklich im herbst oder
winter sein und wollen wir die
freiheiten und zuallererst ist die
impfpflicht erstmal eine
freiheitseinschränkung wirklich
präventiv einschränken ohne dass wir
genau wissen was im herbst und im winter
daraus wird vielen dank bis hierhin
jetzt haben wir schon mal einige
argumente gehört bevor wir weiter
sprechen bringt uns mein kollege heiko
kunzmann nochmal auf den aktuellen stand
der debatte in der es ja neben den
beiden gläubigen gehörten auffassung
auch noch eine vermittelnde position
gibt
das thema impfpflicht hoch emotional
eine orientierungs debatte im bundestag
soll die richtung weisen erst später
entscheiden die abgeordneten über ein
gesetz ohne fraktionszwang drei
positionen zeichnen sich bereits ab
erstens eine impfpflicht ab 18 sie wird
vorgeschlagen von mehreren abgeordneten
von spd grünen und fdp die impfpflicht
sollte befristet werden auf ein bis zwei
jahre und soll für drei dosen gelten für
ungeimpfte werde ein bußgeld fällig im
mittleren dreistelligen bereich zuvor
sollten sie allerdings zeit bekommen die
impfung nachzuholen
ein im register halten die initiatoren
für zu aufwendig zudem gebe es
datenschutzrechtliche bedenken
zweitens eine impfpflicht beispielsweise
ab 50 dafür spricht sich eine gruppe um
den fdp-abgeordneten andrew ullmann aus
zu der auch abgeordnete der grünen
zählen er schlägt ein stufenmodell vor
das mit einem verpflichtenden
arztgespräch beginnt erst wenn trotz
aufklärung die impfquote nicht steige
oder die gesundheitliche versorgung
gefährdet sei soll eine pflicht greifen
drittens keine impfpflicht ein solcher
antrag kam bereits von einer gruppe um
den fdp politiker kubicki er befürchtet
dass der staat eine impfpflicht nicht
umsetzen kann
da holen wir unsere rechts expertin
sarah attacke mit in die runde sache da
liegen also jetzt verschiedene entwürfe
auf dem tisch vom rechtlichen standpunkt
aus gesehen lässt sich denn für alle
gleich gut argumentieren
ganz klar ist egal ob eine impfpflicht
ab 18 oder ab 50 eine impfpflicht ist in
jedem fall ein ganz krasser intensiver
einrichtung unsere grundrechte es geht
ja nicht nur um den kleinen pieks es
geht darum dass wir jemanden dazu
verpflichten nicht zwang es geht nicht
darum dass wir sagen wir halten
niemanden fest und nahmen ihm eine
spritze aber es geht um eine
verpflichtung und die kann man ja auch
nur machen wenn man sie am ende auch
durchsetzt mit beispielsweise bußgeldern
dass man jemanden dazu verpflichtet sich
impfen zu lassen also eine spritze zu
akzeptieren einen wirkstoff vor dem
möglicherweise angst hat ob es nun
begründet ist oder nicht dh wir haben es
hier mit einem ganz krassen
grundrechtseingriff zu tun und egal wie
diese impfpflicht ausgestattet wird es
gibt diesen krassen eingriff deswegen
ist ganz entscheidend egal für welche
variante man sich hier entscheidet was
sagt die wissenschaft was das ist auch
so gehen politiker vor wenn sie gesetze
machen und auch am ende juristen
verfassungsrechtler wenn sie gesetze
überprüfen wie ist der aktuelle stand
der wissenschaft was sagen virologen wie
gut schützt eine impfung wirklich davor
dass wir am ende das ziel erreicht
nämlich dass bei einer nächsten welle
mit einer möglicherweise neuen boutique
mode hatte die wir jetzt noch gar nicht
kennen wir durch eine impfung so gut
geschützt sind dass wir nicht wieder in
einen lock down gehen müssen dass nicht
wieder die krankenhäuser volllaufen und
das heißt wir müssen jetzt die
wissenschaft fragen was machen die
politiker auch und egal welche variante
wir durch spiel es kommen ganz
entscheidend darauf an was die
wissenschaft dazu sagt ja du hast
angesprochen die wissenschaftler fragen
immer gut das machen nicht nur die
politiker das machen auch wir hier in
unserer sendung bevor er das gleich tun
nochmal der kurze hinweis natürlich auch
an euch gerne eure fragen und kommentare
wie immer gerne auch an uns richten und
wir hören mal nach bei professor
friedemann weber virologe von der uni
gießen die frage impfen ja oder nein die
überlässt er zwar den politikern aber er
weist noch mal daraufhin wie wichtig
auch im hinblick auf das was da
eventuell noch kommen wird im herbst
eventuell oder auch später wie wichtig
dafür eine hohe impfquoten in der
bevölkerung ist also ich denke man muss
schon damit rechnen dass im nächsten
herbst auch hier eine corona welle
an rollt wie schwer die werden wird
hängt aber natürlich davon ab wie viel
mobilität in der population besteht je
höher die durchimpfung der bevölkerung
ist desto weniger problematisch ist
einfach eine corona virus ausbruch hier
oder da der sich ja mal passieren wird
aber dieses flächenbrand artige das wird
es dann eigentlich nicht mehr geben und
vor allem eben was die hospitalisierung
an belohnt
herr mordhorst also wäre die impfpflicht
nicht doch der effektivste weg eine hohe
impfquote zu erreichen so wie es auch
neben professor weber andere experten
fordern die impfquote muss ja hoch
gebracht werden das ist durchaus möglich
dass eine impfpflicht dazu führen könnte
dass die impfquote steigt die
durchsetzung probleme wurden aber gerade
schon angesprochen ehrlicherweise und
das wurde auch gerade wieder wiederholt
ist wird abgelehnt von mehreren dass wir
überhaupt wissen wer geimpft ist also
ein ins register also erstmal müsste man
das überhaupt herausfinden man kann ja
nicht die polizei zu jedem nach hause
schicken und den kontrollieren also wenn
man sagt wir wollen durch eine
impfpflicht die impfquote erhöhen dann
gehört dazu unbedingt dass man auch sagt
wie man es durchsetzen möchte und ich
glaube da gibt es erhebliche auch
berechtigte bedenken und auch mit blick
auf die auf den einwurf vorhin wir haben
ja zurzeit eine niedrige
hospitalisierung rate wir haben mal
gesagt unter drei wollen wir gar nichts
machen wir haben eine hospitalisierung
inzidenz von 3,9 zurzeit bei sehr hohen
inzidenz das ist ein problem stellt
keiner in frage aber wir merken doch
dass die hospitalisierung incidents
niedrig bleibt halbwegs konstant ist
jeder ist einer zu viel ist keine frage
aber dennoch zeigt sich zurzeit ist das
problem nicht so groß wie es teilweise
gemacht wird und erst recht nicht so
groß wie es eine allgemeine impfpflicht
begründen würde also die
hospitalisierung zu sprechen sie an das
ist natürlich auch ein ganz wesentlicher
faktor der frau rosenthal schild schon
mit dem kopf ich nehme sie gleich dran
noch mal ganz kurz professor weber er
hat das nämlich nochmal etwas präzisiert
wie hoch seiner meinung nach die
impfquote sein müsste ja das ist also
rein rechnerisch ist man jetzt bei promi
krohn bei über 90 prozent so was nimmt
man an dass man dann so eine art herren
immunität bekommt die aber ja
eingeschränkt eine solche ist weil er
offenbar das virus auch auf einer im
punkt drauf sich ausbreiten kann ist
sicherlich
vermindert und die impfquote hoch genug
ist kann es auch sein dass es sich dann
totläuft ein stück weit aber
jenseits der 90 prozent müsste das schon
sein
gut 90 prozent selbst noch mal gehört
vor rosenthal sie wollten auf ihren
kollegen erwidern
ja weil ich schon glaube das ist wichtig
ist so ein paar sachen geradezurücken
also wenn es darum geht eine endemische
lage herzustellen dann ist das eher der
moment wo wir nicht sagen das virus ist
weg darum geht es nicht es geht darum
dass das virus durchaus auch weiterhin
in der bevölkerung grassierte aber wir
bekommen es eben wie beispielsweise die
grippe und dafür brauchen wir eine
grundimmunisierung die herzustellen und
das sagen alle wissenschaftlichen daten
die wir gerade vorliegen haben das wird
passieren wenn wir drei impfungen
tatsächlich vorliegen haben und deswegen
bin ich auch für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht weil ich möchte dass wir
diese in dem lager also das ist ein
grundschutz für jede und jeden gibt dass
wir die hergestellt bekommen weil ich
nämlich nicht finde dass die freiheits
einschränkungen die wir gerade haben
dass junge menschen nicht wissen sie
mein auslandssemester machen können dass
man nicht weiß wie man seine azubi
prüfung eigentlich schaffen soll das
alles ist ein zustand der so nicht
bleiben darf sondern es muss endlich
dazu kommen dass wir freiheiten
zurückbekommen und es muss aufhören dass
die korona pandemien das habe ich als
lehrerin selbst erlebt nicht immer nur
der der lage hinterher rennt sondern die
politik in dieser frage auch endlich mal
nach vorne guckt und auch massnahmen
trifft die dann wirken und wenn wir im
herbst und winter eine andere lage haben
wollen als jetzt und ich will dass haben
weil ich nicht möchte schülerinnen und
schüler wieder angst haben ob schulen
schließen wir wieder diese debatten
führen wir jetzt dann brauchen wir aus
meiner sicht eine sehr sehr hohe
impfquoten und die endemische lage die
nur aus meiner sicht leider durch eine
impfpflicht möglich ist danke schön ich
trage gerade noch mal zwei punkte hier
aus unserer community vor pro
impfpflicht alles schreiber nrw schreibt
uns über youtube 100% jahr zu
impfpflicht über das alter kann man
diskutieren aber spätestens ab 50 jahren
so seine meinung und miriam g über
youtube ist dagegen sie sagt ich denke
nicht dass eine impfpflicht uns wirklich
helfen würde besonders im hinblick auf
die meist schwächer wirkende omikron
variante sollte jeder selbst entscheiden
können ob er sich impfen lassen möchte
1000 eine nachfrage noch es wird oft
bemängelt dass eben noch nicht alle
anderen weniger
eingreifenden mittel ausgereizt sein um
die impfquote zu verbessern müsste man
da jetzt nicht sagen dass da noch mehr
anstrengungen unternommen werden müssten
bevor es die impfpflicht gibt auch von
seiten der bundesregierung
naja also erst mal haben wir jetzt den
impfstoff ja nun wirklich lange und ich
weiß nicht mir zumindest geht es so dass
ich das wort lasst euch impfen oder
diesen appell eigentlich gar nicht mehr
wegzudenken ist aus meinem umfeld
trotzdem und das will ich klar sagen es
geht hierbei der impfpflicht nicht um
nikon sondern es geht um die nächste
welle im herbst und winter und ich sag
auch klar eine impfpflicht entbindet ja
die politik nicht davon eine vernünftige
impfkampagne zu machen natürlich muss
überall geimpft wäre natürlich muss man
auch den ängsten begegnen die es gibt
also ich bin wirklich nicht dabei zu
sagen hey die impfpflicht kommt und dann
haben wir erstmal alles getan und legen
die füße hoch sondern die impfkampagne
die muss kommen und ich finde auch dass
da fehler passiert sind die ausgeräumt
werden müssen ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass wir das dann auch in dieser
koalition gemeinsam stemmen wollen aber
ich glaube die impfpflicht ist leider
weil sich eben nicht genug menschen
überzeugen lassen ein weg den wir gehen
müssen übrigens auch gerade für viele
junge menschen die mit blick auf ihre
zukunft echte ängste haben die ich auch
sehr gut verstehen kann herr mordhorst
wollen sie dazu vielleicht auch noch mal
direkt was sagen also zurzeit ist es so
dass wir das stimmt mich absolut zu dass
die erforderliche impfquote
wahrscheinlich so bei 90 oder über 90
prozent läge das war auch schon mal
anders und es kann sich mit jeder
variante auch ändern aber selbst wenn
das jetzt so bleibt dann gibt es immer
noch keine garantie dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht erstens dazu führt dass wir
zu einer impfquote über 90 prozent
kommen denn ich habe gerade
durchsetzungs probleme bereits
angesprochen und zweitens kann auch
niemand seriös sagen dass wenn wir eine
allgemeine impfpflicht einführen wir
maßnahmen zurücknehmen das hat bisher
auch niemand seriös gesagt also wenn man
diese diese aufmachung wir machen
entweder impfpflicht oder wir machen
weiter lockdown da finde ich kann man
vor dem vor freiheits themen und vor dem
hintergrund von frei zudem durchaus
darüber diskutieren das macht aber
keiner auch zu recht weil man eben nicht
weiß welche maßnahmen noch notwendig
sein werden das haben wir
leider während der korona pandemie
schmerzlich gemerkt und deswegen würde
ich aufpassen stimmt total die
allgemeine impfpflicht ist kein
allheilmittel
dann dürfen wir aber auch nicht diese
alternative lockdown oder impfpflicht
aufmachen denn so einfach ist es leider
nicht sara wir gucken noch mal auf ein
wort was wir immer wieder hören gleich
von rosenthal auf ein wort das immer
wieder fällt das ist die
verhältnismäßigkeit auch im zusammenhang
mit der impfpflicht kann man dann sagen
dass der sozusagen rechtliche boden der
rahmen für so eine pflicht schon gegeben
ist ganz wichtig ist da die entscheidung
von bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
sogenannten bundes notbremse also zu den
bundes maßnahmen im locker und auch
dieser entscheidung ist auch noch mal
raus zu lesen dass politiker der
gesetzgeber gerade in einer pandemie in
der sich die erkenntnisse sehr stark
wandeln einen enorm großen
entscheidungsspielraum hat
nichtsdestotrotz sind sie nicht daran
gebunden immer im moment alle stimmen zu
hören um eine saubere entscheidung zu
treffen aber der entscheidungsspielraum
ist sehr sehr groß und wenn man mal eine
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung ich finde
das hilft immer enorm also sich an den
juristischen maßstäben hin dann entlang
zu hangeln weil die argumente die wir
gerade gehört haben die spielen da alle
mit rein und das sortiert das ein
bisschen also wofür machen wir die
endlich das ist der legitime zweck das
das erste was wir prüfen damit wir nicht
die nächste welle haben die dazu führt
dass die krankenhäuser so voll sind das
wieder schulen geschlossen werden und
maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen dafür
soll das geht nicht um omikron sondern
um eine mögliche mutante die wir noch
gar nicht kennen das ist ein legitimer
zweck da kann man ganz klar ein haken
dran machen dann ist der nächste punkt
die geeignetheit und da wird schon das
erste mal interessant weil die maßnahmen
also die impfpflicht muss dazu führen
dass dieser zweck gefördert wird auch
noch etwas und da ist die frage wenn
andere länder schauen wie portugal und
spanien oder irland wo in relativ hohe
impfquoten haben haben wir trotzdem
aktuell sehr hohe instanzen ja also
können wir aktuelle stand der
wissenschaft wirklich sagen dass durch
eine höhere impfquote wir wirklich
diesen zweck auch erreichen und muss man
einfach sauber diskutieren kann man so
argumentieren kann man aber auch anders
sehen ja ist das erste mal wo wir da wo
man streiten kann und es auch anders
sehen kann und dann sind wir bei der
erforderlichkeit und und schauen gibt es
nicht ein milderes mittel klar ganz
viele arbeit die auch gleich geeignet
sind und da muss man sich natürlich
einiges anschauen auch in den
vorschlägen steckt schon was drin kann
man nicht einfach mit einem
verpflichtenden im gespräch also das ist
verpflichtend kommende auktion dann sich
danach dürfen ist noch nicht in mildere
mittel das sogar gleich geeignet ist
muss man nicht erst mal
niedrigschwellige angebote schaffen über
die man wirklich stolpert also ich kann
sagen ich bin in person ja noch nie über
ein impfangebot gestoppt ich bin dreimal
geimpft aber aber es aber ich bin nicht
reingestellt und ich hab mich drum
gekümmert ja und als bonus gibt es
verschiedenste mildere mittel und die
frage haben wir da wirklich alles
ausgeschöpft und ist das nicht
möglicherweise gleich geeignet kann man
auch beantworten es gibt keine mails
mittels gleich geeignet ist da gibt es
keine klare wahrheit aber das sind die
punkte die man diskutieren muss und dann
sind wir am ende in der angemessenheit
und da hat der gesetzgeber einfach
wirklich einen großen spielraum weil so
lange dass alles sauber argumentiert
dargelegt und begründet ist und
nachvollziehbar ist kann man eine
impfpflicht einführen das heißt also
verfassungsrechtlich gesehen meine
einschätzung steht das grundgesetz
grundsätzlich kommt darauf an wie es
ausgestaltet ist und dies argumentierte
einer impfpflicht nicht entgegen ok
verstehe ich lese gerade nochmal 2
kommentare vor die uns erreichen zum
einen konnte es action network über
youtube ist es schwierig eine
impfpflicht zu beschließen für ein virus
im herbst dass wir noch nicht kennen mit
einem impfstoff denen es noch nicht gibt
und wir haben die meinung von claire
marie semrau es soll individuell bleiben
wer sich impfen möchte soll das tun wir
nicht möchte soll es bleiben lassen ich
mag es gar nicht wenn jemand zu etwas
gezwungen wird dass er nicht möchte und
man kann das in jedem lebensbereich
übertragen so ihre auffassung da gibt es
mit sicherheit auch gegenargumente aber
wie gesagt dass jetzt die meinung von
ihr so bevor wir weiter machen in der
debatte kleinen moment sarah würde ich
gerne noch einen weiteren aspekt mit
hinzunehmen es wurde ja vorhin auch im
beitrag von heiko kunzmann schon kurz
angesprochen es gibt auch noch eine
vermittelnde lösung eine nach
altersgruppen gestaffelt impfpflicht
vorgetragen von einer gruppe um den
fdp-abgeordneten joe coleman und wir
hören nochmal ihn selbst in einem kurzen
statement würde gerne eingestuften plan
vorstellen und zwar in der ersten stufe
eine verpflichtende aufklärung für die
menschen die noch nicht geimpft sind das
gilt aber auch dann verpflichtend sein
ziel ist es eine freiwillige impfung zu
erreichen mit dieser aufklärung und wir
eine im fluge schließen können dass wir
unseren nächsten winter auch gut
überstehen können sollte jedoch diese
impflücken nicht geschlossen werden wäre
ein zweiter schritt natürlich eine
impfpflicht notwendig eine im
nachweispflicht hier nach den heutigen
daten ab dem alter von 50 jahren ist
geht es sich um ungerechtigkeiten
sondern und medizinische tatsachen dass
ab dem alter von 50 jahren natürlich die
menschen besonders betroffen sind wenn
sie keinen impfschutz haben und das
müssen wir natürlich bekämpfen denn am
ende des tages ist das ziel sehr klar
wir wollen das krankenhaus vor
überforderung schützen
ja das ist mit sicherheit ein ziel das
wir alle haben frau rosenthal der mann
heißt ullmann wurde mir gerade gesagt
nicht unter android zwar aber der
nachname spricht sich wohl deutsch vor
großen teil warum würde es für sie nicht
ausreichen eine impfpflicht für die
altersgruppen einzuführen die ja also
nachweislich am stärksten betroffen sind
bzw die die vor erkrankten warum würde
das für sie nicht reichen
also dass grund argument warum ich finde
die allgemeine impfpflicht bin habe ich
ja jetzt schon mehrfach vorgetragen das
geht mir darum dass wir als bevölkerung
in dem ich sind und wenn wir in dem ich
sein wollen dann hat es zwei vorteile
das eines es gibt eine
grundimmunisierung bei der fast der
mehrheit der bevölkerung also bei allen
die geimpft sind und das sind dann im
besten fall alle und es gibt aber auch
damit die möglichkeit des mutanten gar
nicht so heftig entstehen können wie
wenn wir viel viele ungeimpfte haben das
heißt diese beiden argumente sprechen
für mich dafür eine impfpflicht
einzuführen und da kann ich nicht nur
auf die statistik gucken wo besonders
gefährdete statistisch gesehen sind
sondern wir haben auch kleinere gruppen
die auch betroffen sind die unter 50
sind und ich glaube nicht dass wir damit
die impfquoten erreichen können die zu
nah an de mission situationen führen und
deshalb bin ich für die allgemeine
impfpflicht und ich würde gerne auch
noch ergänzen das ja gerade auch als
starkes gegenargument angeführt wurde
dass es keine durchsetzbarkeit gibt ich
glaube auch bei der frage wie man zb
verpflichtende aufklärung gespräche ohne
ins register was wir gerade nicht haben
denn anbieten und durchführen will das
stellen sich auch sehr sehr viele
umsetzungsfragen bei der impfpflicht die
allgemeinen definitiv auch da ist es
aber so dass es ja schon die debatte in
die richtung gibt dass man sagt es gibt
ein bußgeld ja es kann vielleicht auch
sein dass dann lohnpfändungen erlebt man
wird nicht im gefängnis landen es wird
auch keine zwangsimpfung geben und wir
haben ja auch jetzt schon
stichpunktartige kontrollen in denen
durchaus auch möglich ist dinge
umzusetzen also wenn man zum beispiel
irgendwo falsch parkt wird es ja auch
nicht grundsätzlich irgendwo
kontrolliert und es ist auch nicht so
dass man immer alles überall nachweisen
muss sondern stichproben würden da auch
reichen da bin ich sicher dass das auch
dazu führen würde dass die impfpflicht
durchsetzbar ist herr mordhorst dieser
vermittelnde vorschlag der kam er
immerhin von einem parteikollegen von
ihnen sowieso auffällig die fdp ist
glaube ich in allen gruppen sozusagen
vertreten also da ist ein breites
meinungsbild vorhanden warum oder was
spricht aus ihrer sicht gegen die
gestaffelte lösung ihres kollegen also
allem sei erstmal vorangestellt ist
trifft vollkommen zu aus unserer
fraktion kommen alle möglichen ideen und
sich alle drei anträge sind da vertreten
und das finde ich auch sehr gut und es
zeigt wie respekt vor und offen wir
diese debatte führen ich glaube das ist
in einer so grundsätzlichen frage die
auch öffentlich so viel diskutiert wird
gut und ich bin auch froh dass da der
respekt vorhanden ist und dass es steht
erstmal allem voran egal ob allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 50 oder usw oder gar
keine impfpflicht ich glaube dass wir
die probleme die wir mit einer
allgemeinen pflicht hätten die
durchsetzung probleme und will natürlich
gibt es durchsetzungs problem wenn man
sagt man macht die um eine höhere
impfquote zu bekommen da reichen eben
keine stichproben aus beziehungsweise
vor allem nicht wenn man auf über 90
prozent kommen will ich glaube dass die
sich diese probleme sich bei einem erst
verpflichtenden beratungsgespräch und
dann im pflicht ab 50 wenn das nicht
reicht noch mal multiplizieren also die
probleme der umsetzung herauszufinden
wer ist überhaupt nicht geimpft und in
welchem stadium dann zu gucken wer ist
ab 50 nicht geimpft und das dann auch
noch in einem zweiten schritt umzusetzen
und das überhaupt erstmal zu
organisieren die meisten impfungen
wurden über hausärzte durchgeführt
glaube nicht dass die in dem fall kartei
führen oder dass man das zusammenführen
kann ich finde das in der umsetzung sehr
schwierig auch wenn es als vermitteln
der ansatz vielleicht einige lager
wieder zusammenführt und rein schließt
ich glaube in der umsetzung hätten wir
damit noch größere probleme als mit
einer allgemeinen pflicht also ein
praktisches problem sache das
stufenmodell aus rechtlicher sicht hatte
dass da nicht vielleicht auch einen
gewissen charme weil diese mehrstufig
kite dies ja braucht bei der prüfung der
notwendigkeit der verhältnismäßigkeit
ist ja quasi schon integriert schon
arbeit ganz wichtiger punkt also eine
impfpflicht kann man wirklich nur
einführen wenn man dafür sorgen kann
dass sie auch durchgesetzt wird weil
eine pflicht deren durchsetzbarkeit
mangelhaft ist führt auch zur rechts
ungehorsam und lässt unser gesamtes
rechtssystem immobilien also es ganz
zentral dass der gesetzgeber der daran
arbeitet vorher hat das ihm vorher klar
ist ob er am ende eine pflicht anordnet
die auch durchsetzen kann auf welche
weise auch immer und da ist das nächste
große probleme und das ist dass wir
wirklich nicht wissen aktuell wer
geimpft ist und wer nicht und das ist ja
anders bei der grippeimpfung war dass
ihm die krankenkassen dorf da wissen wir
es ganz klar und es wäre auch wichtig
jetzt unabhängig von der impfpflicht das
zu erfassen damit man auch weiß wo wo
sind denn ballungsräume wer lässt sich
nicht impfen um dann auch zu wissen wie
kann man die ansprechen ja also dass wir
auch wieder vorgelagert vor einer
pflicht von der man wissen muss wie man
sie durchsetzen kann bevor man sie
einführt dass man sie dass man erfasst
und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was
bislang nicht erfolgt ist wer geimpft
ist und wer nicht geimpftes um auch
adäquat darauf reagieren zu können und
zu wissen in diesem stadtteil haben sich
90 prozent nicht impfen lassen da kommen
jetzt ganz viele aufklärungs busse oder
aber wir müssen unterschiedlich
ansprechen oder auch zu sehen wo gibt es
hot spots ja also das dass das ist nicht
erfolgt und das ist ein grundsätzliches
problem also die frage auch der der
erfassung und der praktischen
umsetzbarkeit
cdu und csu die haben beim thema im
pflichtige zahl die beiden parteien
möglich vergessen wiederholt von der
bundesregierung gefordert eine klare
vorgabe zu liefern außerdem brauche es
ein ins register so war es auch heute
wieder vom unions fraktionsvorsitzenden
zu hören und das hören wir uns gerade
auch nochmal an wir sind immer noch der
meinung dass es besser gewesen wäre wenn
die bundesregierung bei so einer
wichtigen frage eine meinung gehabt
hätte 1 schält sich hier schon heraus es
ist ganz ganz wichtig zumindestens
mittel und langfristig auch eine lösung
mit einem ins register hinzubekommen ins
register ist unseres erachtens notwendig
um auch weitere schritte vornehmen zu
können
soweit also ralph brinkhaus die aber
sagen unsere beiden gäste zu dieser
kritik aus dem zum einen kommt zu wenig
führung von der ampel das ja ein immer
wieder gehörter vorwurf zum anderen
braucht ist ein impf register frau hosen
teil wie es ihrer einschätzung
also erstmal muss ich sagen dass ich
genau in diesem punkt und das ist ja
jetzt auch grad schon angesprochen
worden ist super wichtig finde dass wir
eine offene debatte haben dass es eben
gerade weil es um eine ethische frage
gibt auch wirklich um das gewissen jedes
einzelnen und jeder einzelnen
abgeordneten geht und genau das machen
wir jetzt und dann kann es keine
bundesregierung geben die einfach meinen
gesetzesvorschlag hin knallt und sagt so
wir können ja machen was ihr wollt aber
das hier ist schon das was wir von euch
erwarten so kann es meiner sichtlich
laufen deswegen sehe ich darin ehrlich
gesagt und auf eine führungsstärke und
auch ein großes vertrauen in das
gewissen der abgeordneten werden wir
dann im register sprechen da kann ich
sehr gut nachvollziehen gerade mit blick
darauf dass man eben immer angebote raus
schicken kann dass man auch die
datenlage die katastrophales für
deutschland dass man dir auch angehen
kann finde aber interessant dass das
gerade von der union kommt die erlanger
jetzt im netz als hättest
gesundheitsministerium hatte ich glaube
dass es tatsächlich viel zu lange dauert
jetzt dieses im register aufzubauen und
das dann noch mit der impfpflicht zu
verknüpfen da werden wir am ende genau
da sein dass nämlich die impfpflicht bis
zum herbst und winter eigentlich keinen
effekt hat und deshalb finde ich es
schade aber ich glaube nicht dass das an
der stelle sinnvoll ist und dass uns das
weiter bringt aber ich will damit
trotzdem ich sagen dass die debatte vom
tisch ist ich glaube das kann man auch
unabhängig von der impfpflicht dann
nochmal weiter diskutieren und da muss
man wahrscheinlich auch ein paar
schritte nach vorne machen herr motors
zu wenig führung von der ampel und es
braucht dann im register ihrer
einschätzung also das find ich
tatsächlich auch grundsätzlich ein
problematisches verständnis von politik
wenn gute politik bedeutet dass alles
von der regierung vorgegeben und
durchgezogen wird also gerade bei
medizin ethischen fragen haben wir eine
sehr gute erfahrung mit diesen
orientierungs und dann gewissens
debatten und entscheidungen auch gemacht
also das thema organspende gab es tolle
debatten ist mittlerweile auch ziemlich
befriedet zumindest in der öffentlichen
diskussion zur sterbehilfe das waren
sternstunden des parlaments auch unter
einer cdu geführten oder unionsgeführten
regierung das sollten wir nicht
kleinreden ich finde das ist etwas sehr
sehr gutes das ist eine stärke eine
stärke unserer demokratie und ich glaube
es wird sich auch in den nächsten wochen
wieder zeigen wie stark unsere
demokratie
seine grundsätzlichen fragen aushält ich
weiß ist eine kleine umgewöhnung für
herrn brinkhaus aber ich glaube das wird
moderner politik in deutschland viel
mehr gerecht verstehe jetzt ist es
natürlich so dass der vorwurf immer
wieder im raum steht dass gerade die
führenden köpfe der bundeskanzler aber
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister sich
der auffallend zurückhaltend sage ich
mal verhalten in dieser frage und es
wird immer wieder kolportiert dass
könnte geschehen eben auch mit rücksicht
auf die fdp wie begegnen sie dieser
einschätzung
also ich empfinde da wenig rückhalt oder
wenig zurückhaltung der von ihnen
genannten beteiligten olaf scholz hat
sich bereits im parlament klar geäußert
dass er als abgeordneter eine allgemeine
impfpflicht befürwortet genauso der
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ich glaube es ist einfach und
das müssen wir vielleicht auch wieder
ein bisschen lernen dass es
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt dass man
die ausfällt und dass man das nicht als
defizitär oder so was empfindet sondern
dass man das als bereichernd empfindet
das und dazu das parlament da ist diese
debatten zu befrieden wir brauchen eine
starke regierung ich glaube wir machen
das als regierung auch im großen und
ganzen sehr gut die regierung bietet
auch hilfe dabei an gesetzesentwürfe zu
machen oder sonstige informationen zu
liefern und so sollte es doch laufen die
erste gewalt ist das parlament und ich
glaube diese stärke sollten
unterstreichen und nicht kleinreden
vielen dank herr mordhorst vielen dank
auch noch mal bei unserer bei jessica
rosenthal juso-chefin und
bundestagsabgeordneten danke ihnen
beiden ganz herzlich wir haben ein
zeitliches limit dass wir nicht
überschreiten wollen ich danke ihnen
ganz wie gesagt noch mal aus ganzem
herzen dass sie mitgemacht haben bei
dieser diskussion und eben dass sie die
zeit auch heute abend für uns
aufgebracht haben ich würde aber gerne
noch mit meiner kollegin
sarah attacke weiter sprechen denn es
gibt noch ein argument oder einen punkt
auf den ich finde ich auch noch gerne
eingehen würde und da geht es nämlich um
das thema medikamente wir haben da eine
zuschrift bekommen von news junkies über
youtube wenn es den crooner medikamente
gibt braucht man dann eine impfung
überhaupt noch und dazu haben wir auch
noch mal eine einschätzung von professor
friedemann weber der sich auch noch mal
zu dieser frage geäußert hat wie denn
aktuell überhaupt der stand ist was
medikamente angeht auch gerade im
zusammenhang mit dem zusammenspiel
medikamente und impfung
das kann natürlich auch helfen die
schwere verläufe abzumildern ganz klar
aber das ist natürlich ein stück weit im
prinzip das modell vorher löcher gegen
vorher melder also es ist schon immer
besser wenn man im voraus dass schon
vermeidet
und durch prävention aber wenn das eben
auch aus irgendeinem grund schief
gegangen ist dann ist es großartig dass
die medikamentöse behandlung jetzt immer
immer besser wird bei cola virus ist ja
wirklich auch viel arbeit reingesteckt
wurden
dann ist das vielleicht auch mal ein
punkt den wir kurz aufgreifen können
also jetzt gerade auch in rechtlicher
hinsicht wenn man jetzt irgendwie guckt
impfpflicht geboten oder nicht inwieweit
spielt da die verfügbarkeit von
medikamenten eine rolle jetzt wird er
grundsätzlich trotzdem so dass auch bei
medikamenten wurde auch gerade gesagt
dass eine maßnahme im nachhinein ist und
nicht dazu führt dass jemand eben nicht
behandelt werden muss und die ganz
zentrale frage ist wirklich wie schaffen
wir es dass nicht zu viele menschen
gleichzeitig im krankenhaus behandelt
oder sogar auf den sieg station
behandelt werden müssen und es kann
natürlich sein dass durch medikamente
nur noch sehr viele menschen im
krankenhaus behandelt werden aber auch
das kann das gesundheitssystem aus dem
gleichgewicht finden kippten das heißt
dass man natürlich trotzdem mit
einbeziehen also es bleibt dabei um zu
beurteilen ob es eine rechtliche impft
oder ob es rechtlich angezeigt ist oder
auch verfassungsrechtlich durch jetzt wo
es endlich einzuführen hängt davon ab
wie der stand der wissenschaft aktuelles
und dann kann man natürlich auch darauf
blicken das aktuell medikamente auf dem
markt sind die dazu führen dass man
kroner behandeln kann und man kann
natürlich auch nur den impfstoff
beurteilen den wir aktuell haben und
auch nur die variante sehen die wir
aktuell haben und all das muss man ins
bild und im vergleich setzen was mich
aber eben auch schon angesprochen
wirklich nachhaltig erstaunt ist dass
wir jetzt ins jahr 3d pandemie gehen und
bis heute die datenlage in deutschland
wer steckt sich wann wie so anja wie
verbreitet sich dieses virus genau es
wurde nie
ausgeführt dass jeder der infiziertes
einfachen zehn fragen kann ja auch
anonym sein ausfüllt ja wir haben bis
heute eine gewisse nicht wäre es gift
schon wer es nicht günstiger werden bis
heute eine derart dünne daten und wir
müssen ja trotzdem maßnahmen ergreifen
und diese maßnahmen ob nun eine
impfpflicht oder einloggt kann nur
erfolgen auf grundlage der aktuellen
datenlage und wir können froh sein dass
um uns herum andere länder auch mit dem
virus kämpfen und deutlich effektiver
und effizienter und geordneter daten
sammeln und sie zur verfügung stellen
weil es doch schwierig ist auf dieser
dünnen datenlage mir immer wieder
maßnahmen oder sogar ein
grundrechtseingriff wir die impfpflicht
zu begründen das nochmal die rechtliche
einordnung zu diesem aspekt medikamente
mit sicherheit auch etwas worauf viele
warten dass vielleicht auch noch mal zum
hintergrund die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema will noch in
diesem monat über die zulassung des us
präparats paket entscheiden also wie
gesagt für viele mit sicherheit auch
eine lösung aber auch wir haben es
gerade noch mal vom fachmann auch gehört
im vergleich zu impfpflicht mit
sicherheit nicht ganz so effektiv
zumindest was die gesamtgesellschaft
angibt vielen dank für euer interesse
heute abend an diesem thema die beiden
kollegen aus dem bundestag aber schon
verabschiedet sagt tacke dankeschön für
deine einschätzung hier bei uns im
studio und euch allen einen schönen
abend noch mal für die zuschriften und
eure fragen einen schönen abend und bis
demnächst